hi there Steve here to talk about
languages and of course if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe to my
channel today I want to talk a little
bit more about our mini story project
you'll remember last time I talked about
these many stories that we're creating
not.we i've actually commissioned the
writer to write them very interesting
little vignettes of everyday life that
incorporate the basic patterns and
structures of english and i said let's
get some interest in translating these
into other languages whether it be
languages we have that link or other
languages farsi indonesian whatever
might be and we've had a good response
from people offering to translate these
stories into a variety of languages and
so we're coordinating this and we're
gonna be contacting every one of you to
try and you know divide the work up so
that one person doesn't have to do all
of the stories i'm working on their
greek part of it because i'm learning
Greek and Pablos and Greece is recording
these stories on his iPhone and I must
say the audio quality is very good so we
want to go forward but today I'm
thinking that okay it's one thing to
translate these stories into other
languages and by and large it works
because it's been my conviction for the
longest time that because I've learned
I'm now on my 17th language that the
basic concepts and structures and things
that we want to say in a language are by
and large the same in all languages the
issues are the same obviously we're
dealing with you know people and things
like nouns we're dealing with descriptor
descriptions like adverbs and adjectives
of different kinds and brother go in the
sentence we're dealing with basically
past present future there's variations
on these tenses but essentially
something that happened in the past
that's happening now or them will happen
in the future we deal with maybe
probability might or have to should
ought to or why because or in order to
they
for we deal with you know in by on with
in other words prepositions or in case
in some languages the nouns or
adjectives change depending on whether
it's by in add from but the fundamental
concepts and the things we want to say
in my opinion from my point of view on
the other hand all of these things we
end up having to say them and all these
different languages so - the key is to
get interesting stories then they can be
translated and they still work for
learning other languages the advantage
then there is that we have translations
the structure of the stories also I
think is key to making it a good
learning experience but what I want to
get to today is what I want to get some
feedback on is we will continue with our
English stories and use them as the core
from which we translate into other
languages but obviously these are
written and they will have an English
language cultural bias now when we
translate them we try to localize them
we change the names from you know George
- George how you know or or Pedro but
another minor changes however it would
really be fun to have stories written
originally in other languages by people
who can create interesting little
vignettes okay so typically the format
is 10 or 12
not too long sentences describing
someone doing something out of everyday
life and then the same story from
another point of view which might be
tense which might be person you know
rather than he or she it's I and then
followed by questions and one of the
things as I said that filter did so well
and his questions is that the answer is
contained in the question so you don't
have to try to remember what was in the
story what this does is it
creates a tremendous amount of
repetition and it gives you a chance if
you want to to try an answer to try and
say something in response to what you're
listening to
however everything is in the target
language unlike some systems like
Pimsleur where you're being prompted in
your language which in my view is not as
good other people may disagree it's not
as good as having everything in the
language you are learning so what I'm
asking today is are there people who are
interested in writing some original
stories of everyday life little
vignettes on the same basic format but
in Farsi or Vietnamese or Quechua or
whatever it might be so that we grow
this project so it's not just
translating from English into these
other languages which is still key and I
want to do that I want to get through
that part of the project but on an
ongoing basis we can make this a project
where people are creating stories
translating stories so that if we get a
story in you know Slovakian that someone
can translate that into English and
always be one of the translations done
by native speakers or native speakers
write the stories and native speakers
translate these into their own language
and we just get this tremendous
mushrooming of these stories the other
advantage of having stories written in
other languages rather than English is
that while the fundamental concepts in
any language that you know whatever it
might be past present future
you know comparative support like big
Biggers biggest or all of these things
are similar in our languages the
languages deal with them somewhat
differently so the translation to a
largest networks however there are
specific issues to specific languages
you know particles and Japanese so I'll
touch you up I'm not dying whatever you
know and so and some languages you know
cases in Slovak
whatever it might be there are verbs of
motion which are a bigger issue in
Slavic languages so to some extent
someone writing a story in another
language other than English may develop
stories that focus on these issues a
little more and so that when we
translate them they're still good for
learning say English if we translate
them back into English but they're
really powerful for learning those
languages were where those specific
issues are what caused problems now it
is not difficult to google and find out
what are the major problems you know
learners of a particular language have I
was able to google what are the major
issues for learners of English so that
we can identify what these so if I'm a
native speaker of Russian and I'm gonna
create some stories in Russian then it's
not difficult to find out that most
foreigners have trouble with version
motion they have trouble with you know
the the aspect of verbs and so forth so
that if I'm a Russian speaker a native
speaker then I would create some stories
hopefully interesting stories that would
focus on those issues so there you have
it it's again on the subject of as many
stories but I would be interested in
your reaction to actually creating
original stories in other languages
which other people with them translate
back into their native language as part
of this call it mini story language
promotion language learning project that
we're developing here so I look forward
to your feedback and thank you for
listening
[Music]